le ballon de la victoire pour cet
entraîneur de football et nouveaux
sénateurs d'alabama
une célébration à l'image de la soirée
les prochaines années seront cruciales
et il semble que ce sont les
républicains qui contrôleront le sénat
en plus du leader mitch mcconnell la
plupart des têtes d'affiché du parti ont
été réélus dont lindsey graham
fidèle allié du président roh pigatto
mais le message est clair
malgré une victoire en arizona de
l'astronaute mark kelly
les démocrates n'obtiendront pas la
majorité souhaitait de sénateur ils ont
même perdu des plumes à la chambre des
représentants outre la réélection
d'alexandria occasio cortese étoile
montante du parti et de ses collègues de
ce qu'elle appelle la brigade la soirée
ne s'est pas tout à fait passé comme
prévu de ce républicain de 25 ans
devient le plus jeune élu de l'histoire
moderne au congrès et celle ci est la
première adeptes du mouvement
conspirationnistes qui ordonne à être
élu ce candidat républicain mort de la
kfw 19 le mois dernier a même été élu au
dakota du nord
mais une première aussi pour les
démocrates sarabeth bras et dès la
première sénatrice transgenres des états
unis élu à l'assemblée législative du
delaware plus de diversité plus de
femmes c'est aussi ça le portrait du
congrès américain
ici sébastien desrosiers radio canada
montréal